that's a good cookie oh hello everybody
my name is markiplier but then again you
probably already knew that anyway this
is another vlog I know it's been a
little bit since the last one the last
one being New Year's and I said that I
was gonna do them every week but I've
been stupid busy for the past few months
I think I said that in one of the past
videos I did but one of the reasons why
I've been so busy is because I am going
to be moving to Los Angeles like the
name of this video says I am finally
going to be leaving Cincinnati for the
mecca of YouTube and entertainment that
is Los Angeles now that doesn't mean
that I'm gonna be leaving like tomorrow
or at the end of this week there's still
a few months out I think at least two
months is when my lease comes up here
but I'm gonna be leaving Wednesday two
days from now to go look for a place now
what this means is nothing really for
you guys because well I mean it means
something for you guys but it doesn't
mean that anything's gonna be the
problem or anything I'm not gonna stop I
can it doesn't mean that I'm gonna be
making any less videos the primary
reason that I'm moving out there so that
I can be closer to other youtubers and
work with collaborations with other
people more closely and be you know
engrained in the Society of YouTube and
be able to use YouTube space and stuff
like that I mean Cincinnati is great and
I plan to return to it at some point in
the future but you know I I need to be
out there for what I'm doing right now
and this is weird because I've been in
Cincinnati pretty much my whole life I
mean I was born in Hawaii and then move
to Cincinnati when I was three so I've
kind of been here for how old of my head
I'm 24 so 21 years ish I've been in
Cincinnati yet I've never lived anywhere
else that I could remember so there's
gonna be a big move for me that's why
I'm taking my time I'm gonna find the
right place a real good place and then
make it a very slow process of getting
all the things that I need over there
and getting my apartment set up there or
house or whatever I'm doing before I
actually do it so anyway that's the big
thing that's the main thing going in my
life and that's what I'm really planning
out right now
that um today you know it's hard to keep
track of anymore but we hit 1.4 million
subscribers we got uh uh I mean it's
four hundred thousand more people than
we had just about a two and a half
months ago because we hit a million it
like the end of October the very end
October thirtieth I believe and now it's
January something-or-other and we're at
1.4 million in and that's absolutely
unbelievable we may get to two million
before my original goal to get 1 million
and I'm blown away by that I'm so
grateful for everything that you guys
have done thank you so much for
believing in me and believing in the
channel the other thing that I wanted to
talk about is I mentioned in New Year's
my new goal for a charity amount for
this year um I also wanted to mention
that I haven't really been planning an
event to do like a t-shirt sale or a
livestream this month because I've been
so busy busy with other projects that
aren't ready to tell you about yet I've
been struggling to even catch up or keep
up with my normal videos which I've been
putting a lot more work in do than I
usually have so overall I'm literally
swamped from the time I get out of bed
to the time I go to bed I'm working on
something or another but um I just want
to let you guys know I haven't forgotten
about it I haven't you know let it slip
or anything it's on my mind and I'm
hoping that I'm gonna be able to do it
maybe next weekend or if not the early
February but it's gonna happen so don't
worry about it so I'll let you guys know
about what the cause were going for what
the thing is what the livestream is
gonna be all about when it's gonna be
about all those details will come later
but the main point of this is just to
let you guys know that I'm in super busy
and I'm going to be even busier and when
I get to LA I'll be even busier when I'm
working with uh other people like
everyday I can't wait to be out in LA
just because there's so many cool people
that I want to work with and then
there's so many cool things that are
going to come out of it and it's gonna
open up a million more opportunities for
me in terms of like you know voice
acting and
using YouTube space and making sketch
comedies and and just making overall
cool stuff for you guys so it's all
gonna be beneficial I just have to bust
my hump to get through it that's all I
gotta say for that but just thank you
guys for constantly believing in me and
I hope you guys have noticed that you
know I've been putting a lot more effort
into my videos and I mentioned this on a
live stream where I did an impromptu
live stream last week that I was putting
a lot more work into it but you know it
means so much to me that I can do these
weird little experimental things and you
guys still love it because just doing
this for you is an absolute honor and
I'm so excited for what comes in the
future so I will let you know more
progress about my move to LA as it comes
along
I don't know I'm doing Oh cookie clicker
it's a reindeer I got going I'm a golden
card yeah alright well addicted I've
reset two times already so anyway what
hmm there are beautiful beautiful people
to hold alright so thank you guys so
much for everything that you've done
support me it's it just it warms my
heart to know that you're there for me
and I can't wait I can't wait to tell
you guys about the stuff that's
happening it's gonna be so cool so
anyway so thank you all so much for
watching know Ida tations blah blah blah
I hope you had a wonderful day check out
my highlight videos I started those
doing a thing tongs FFF yeah anyway
thank you all again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye oh and as
you've probably already noticed I
started putting fan art at the beginning
of some videos I just wanted to show my
appreciation for some of the incredible
pieces of art that people have made for
me and I wanted to make sure that the
rest of the community saw it as well to
give you some attention so if you've got
a piece of fan art that you want
showcased or you want me to see please
look in the description below to find
the link to the fan deviantART page
that's the best place for me to find it
and who knows it may just end up in a
video thanks again bye-bye
YouTube layout that doesn't matter
anything at all
um this is another vlog because I have
some important news I don't know
o reindeer another golden cookie that's
like got a clicky click got a click with
two fingers yeah yeah oh yeah it's good
that's a good cookie that's good and
upgrade
I got a release of Grandma clips pretty
soon oh yeah are you still doing here